Britain's Prime Minister says her
country needs to do more to fight
Islamic extremism Isis claims
responsibility for Saturday's attack
that killed seven people at least 48
others were hurt including two Americans
it was Britain's third terror attack
since March police are holding at least
11 people after rates this morning and
over the weekend the three main suspects
drove abandoned two people on London
Bridge before crashing the vehicle
the attackers jumped out of the car and
then began stabbing people in a crowded
restaurant area now police shot and
killed all three suspects they're on the
scene Charlie Daggett is at Westminster
Bridge where another attack killed five
people back in March with a look at how
Londoners are responding to this latest
attack charlie good morning good morning
things have changed here since
Saturday's attack most notably these
barriers that popped up overnight here
on Westminster Bridge and others to stop
vehicles from driving onto the sidewalk
but for a country that coined the phrase
keep calm and carry on
strength through adversity as a matter
of patriotic pride they've had no effect
on me but except for sheer emotion of
how the horror of it all
Londoner Helen her boat Ptolemies
reaction to the terror attacks kind of
sums it up they're not living in fear
I'm not living in fear no it's a
sentiment we heard most from commuters
returning to work this morning
like Simon Darlie you might be a bit
more aware but there's no worries with
it at all just get on with it get on
with it that's what we do getting on
with it despite the fact that Saturday's
rampage is the third terrorist attack in
three months from plowing down
pedestrians on Westminster Bridge
knifing a policeman to death to the
suicide bombing that left 22 dead at the
ariana grande concert in Manchester yet
out of the chaos and carnage on Saturday
nights emerged stories of courage when
Gerard Valle saw the three attackers
knifing a woman he tried to draw them
away all Schiedam UK was murderers
terrorists and then they look to me
you're yelling at them up yeah I think I
picked up a stall or share I think I was
trying to chuck it erm I think I might
have it one of a nearby a fruit
um glasses trying to get him to chase me
to get him away onto the main moto so
the police could see where they were and
obviously shoot him or take him down
while video of a man carefully clutching
a glass of beer as he fled Saturday's
violence made him an unlikely hero it's
not to say the terror attacks have had
no impact at all it's just that most
have chosen to be more invested in
sadness and anger than fear London Mayor
Sadiq Khan has announced at a vigil will
be held early this evening in honor of
those killed in Saturday's attack and in
his words to show the world that were
united in the face of those who seek to
harm us and our way of life
Nora all right Charlie d'Agata in London
thank you